The Joe Rogan experience. I kind of wish I had that with like a wife.
That's why I'm so scared of marriage because you change so much from just high
school to now or college to now, and then you get, um,
you get married and then you change again.
Maybe when you're 62 and then just stuck with this a plus size
lady, and you don't know what the hell to do and how to get out.
And you can't meet anybody new because you're 62.
That's the problem with the contract of marriage, right?
That's the problem as it is a legal contract. And if it goes great antiquated,
it is in a lot of ways. Um, it's very good for, uh,
ensuring that there's like, uh, there's a bond.
That's not just your word. Yeah. You know, it's legal.
So if you do try to leave,
the woman at least has some sort of financial recourse in some case,
the men every now and then one of us we've we put one on the board. Right.
Right, right. LeBron money.
From divorces. He's the goat.
Yeah. I think it's like when a black cop shoots a white guy,
I'm sure it's the same with the black community. Or like when OJ one,
I lived in a black neighborhood and I could hear the yelling and people were
going nuts. Yeah.
Every now and then a guy wins. Who else do we know of that is made money off a,
like a high profile divorce where the woman had all the money.
New one that just came out with the actress that just divorced a guy.
And he was a nobody. And he's cleaning up. But I can't think of who it is. Yeah.
Give him that a goop, JMO. I don't know how you would look that up, but yeah.
Guy killing it with hot actress. Wife. Yeah. I don't know.
But there is no better line. Yes. Oh.
Kevin got fat. Like he just.
He was hot. He was a hunk. Some hot, sorry.
Hunka burning. Love. You had a six pack and look great. Yeah. Hot.
What is that would look like now? I don't know. Now we got very big.
Oh, there he is. The bottom, right? Yeah. He's a chubster. He got very busy.
Not so bad though.
Got a little gut there. [inaudible] scare. Oh Jesus. That's crasher. Never.
Oh my God. He's got big clothing. He got big. But also, you know,
he's taken care of the kids under low stress.
True. True. It's funny how all that stuff rolls, rolls out the window.
When it's like, when the tables flip, you know, it's like, Hey,
women need their money to, and then when the guys like, I need my money.
It's like, Oh, what are you doing? And you're like, well,
that's what you've been doing. You know? It's like outcome. When it flips.
Now you're mad. Ah, I'm a.
You see what I'm saying? But I don't want to, we don't have to get into it.
Great GFI. Do you think that, uh, I mean,
it's just the non-traditional roles, right?
And when a woman is killing it and she's making that money, there's a,
an understanding that more women have been up.
Wow. Okay. Well that, that's probably true. It is.
It has to be the beatings and it seems natural. Right? When you think about it,
like the woman gets the money, like, yup.
Yeah. It seems natural. But if you think about the man gets the money like you,
like, what, why does he.
It doesn't feel right. It feels wrong,
which is so cool about comedy because those things are imprinted in people.
So when you make a joke, the wrong way, you make a fat guy joke.
Ha ha make a fat lady joke. No, no. And the audience will tell you that.
And so all the PC, all the tweets, all the. You can tell me this all day,
but I got to focus group.
Right here, dude.
I saved a body positivity meme that someone tried to get
out there. A pot for men with guts. Yeah.
Like a fat man. Your body's beautiful. Like, like get the out of it.
They were trying it.
It's not gonna work. Not gonna work. Yeah. It only works on females. It's true.
It's true. Big is beautiful. It's never about Chris Christie.
You know it's about Lena Dunham or whoever the.
Exactly. Exactly. Well, there's, you know, it's it's and it,
the feeling that they're getting from,
this is a supportive feeling from other females, men. Right?
Never support you for being a fat. Never, never, never. They never like, yeah,
bro. Who cares, man? You look awesome with your fat gut.
Like never.
She healthier. I mean, it's a little meaner out of the gate,
but at least we're being honest. We're keeping it real.
Uh, yeah. Or would not letting them get away with something. Yeah. There you go.
I mean, that's what I'm saying, friends. If they love you,
they're not going to let you get away with that. And I'm like, bro,
you are fat as. You're like, no, really? Like.
Exactly. Yeah. And that's a friendly thing. You know,
like if I had a fat son and Corona was hitting, I would be like, Hey man,
like I don't care what you look like.
You can do your thing and eat all the chocolate you want, but I'm worried.
You'll get hit with the COVID more because you're fat and you will,
and you will statistic. And then people are like, Hey,
you can't talk to him like that. That's why I'm like, I'm worried about my son.
you.
If it's, if it's a woman, you'd be body shaming.
But when they tried body shingled, they tried to say,
it's body shaming on a man. It doesn't really stick. Right.
It doesn't doesn't stick it. Doesn't stick. Stick. Yeah. What's going on here,
Kelly.
Clarkson's the one that was the random Blackstock seeking six figure monthly
payments. Pow. Wow. How long were they married?
He wants 5.2 million a year. A year. He's got a year.
He also requested Clarkson cover $2 million in attorney's fees.
Oh my God. Wow. Oh my God.
That's insane. Killing it. That's insane Lex duck.
But here's the thing. The difference there's there's a great difference.
Seven year marriage. That's great in a year, but here's the,
is he taking care of the children? Do they have children together?
That is the question.
35 Of the four 36 was for child support.
He needs child support money from her on top of the 301 and spousal,
probably on the road a lot, you know, she's.
Was he like the manager or some? Was it one of those deals?
Because those deals get real tricky when the man becomes the manager and it's
very difficult for the woman to get away from the manager. That's in boyfriend,
girlfriend deals with girlfriends, the singer or husband, wife, or the dad.
What's equal says he is an American talent manager. So
[inaudible].
There was any question that some of those are Weasley.
Those numbers. Yeah.
Yeah, definitely. Just to request that, Oh my God,
you want how much I know all that management,
Joe Jackson was a psycho and I think Jessica Simpson's dad was a real weird,
I never obtained a license to legally operate as a talent agent. According to.
Of course not. He was the client. He didn't have to. Yeah, there you go.
Catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free. Only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.